the setup is a normal deck of cards now
he's a cross-section of a normal taking
cars and in case you don't play around
with cards very much let me tell you
what's in the deck of cards for starters
you've got all of these different values
of cards that most people up somewhat
familiar with then you can see it starts
from an ace which depending on the game
you're playing is either worth of one or
more than a king
okay ace two three four all the way up
to ten and then you get these on these
picture cards Jack queen king in that
order
okay now as you can see if you replace
the ace with a1 you've got ten numbers
and then three I think they're also
called court cards sometimes because of
Jack Queen King so 10 plus 3 you've got
13 cards and then you've got 4 copies of
those because you can name them right
what are our suits over here they're
four of them diamonds hot clubs and
spades so what you get is the same 13
cards in diamonds the same 13 it costs
the same in clubs spades so if you've
got 13 different kinds of cards and four
copies of all of them then in total
you've got good so 4 times now you will
notice that does not include a joker
okay for starters no games that I
actually know what I mean I'm sure they
aren't they exist because Joker's exist
no games that I know of actually rely on
a joker and secondly whenever they say a
standard deck of cards they only mean
these ones okay so therefore your sample
space is always going to be 52 from
sample space alright I hope I stored
long enough now have a look at the first
question this is part a it says what's
the probability of not drawing out a six
of clubs are you looking the same with
me yeah
this is exercise 8h question nine part a
so how am I going to write this well
using this sum this complement notation
I'm going to say the probability of six
of clubs but I actually want it to be
not a six of clubs right so I'm going to
put my my complement sign over the top
okay does that make sense
so there's my probability the six of
clubs
yes stay with me stay with me so the
first thing I'm gonna do yeah if you
listen you'll find out the first thing
we're gonna do is I'm going to notice I
could work out how many cards are not
the six of clubs but a much better way
is to do this common theme right so I'm
going to use this line or rather this
line okay and I'm gonna say the
probability of not getting a six is six
of clubs is one takeaway that
probability okay so that's fairly easy
to work out if you say what's the
probiem is six of clubs here are all
your clubs in heinous 13 of them right
which i haven't we haven't snuck off and
only one of them is a six okay this is a
six of spades this is a six of hearts
this is six of diamonds so none of them
are the ones I'm interested in there's
only one in the entire deck make sense
so therefore if there's only one in the
whole deck what's the probability
I
I forgot to mention color actually
you'll notice if you can squint hard
enough consider the small the diamonds
in abouts are out red suits closet
spades are black suits so they don't ask
what about the problem of getting a red
six which would be well there are two
red six is not there there's only one
six of clubs
this is 51 52 yeah fancy yeah that's
question I don't have an automatic okay
I'll skip over B because these the same
can you look at C for me you look at C
read C now I'll tell you a little bit of
a secret see the way I've set up this
question on the board over there on the
right hand side okay when we're marking
this thing that number at the end the 51
or 52 the pot that's usually the most
important length of the odds-on okay
when you're doing questions like this in
probability that 51 or 52 is actually
the least important part of the entire
question because someone can guess if
you want to people too or you can get 51
or 52 the wrong way this is the part
that demonstrates understanding okay so
all the effort should really be I mean
it's just like when we were doing
questions on like finance and I can be
look tell me what's going on write
something please don't just give me
numbers now keep that in mind as you
look at Part C it says what's the
probability of not getting an ace of
diamonds are at King of Diamonds what's
the probability of not getting an ace of
diamonds or king of diamonds so this is
Part C
so please pay attention to the way that
I write this okay the probability of
getting not an ace of diamonds or King
of Diamonds yes they do
I checked that it does imply it's a it's
not always clear but they do mean the
same to me okay
you're 11 are you ready this is where I
begin
look at how I've set things up on the
board already I've got a compliment
there so the first thing I'm gonna do is
get rid of that compliment using this
thing okay so I'm gonna say that's one
takeaway there probably of it actually
happening rather than not happening so
that make sense so this is the
probability of Ace of Diamonds walking
you guys okay now please note I put
words in there I put commas only put
slashes that kind of thing because that
tells me what to do in the next item
tells me what to write when I combine
probabilities like ace and King do I add
these or do I multiply them I'm going to
add right because this this or this
they're separate events right so
therefore I'm gonna write one takeaway
now I'm gonna put a big pair of brackets
here because these two things are
together I'm subtracting both of them
okay the probability of that ace plus
the probability of the King with me
watch the brackets as well an easy way
to get this wrong is to say oh I had to
add right there's a minus sign there and
then I'll put a plus sign but if you
don't have the brackets it changes your
pants off completely
it changes for something fun that 17:16
a second okay now I'm done these are
just two specific cards and only one of
each just like with this one over here
right so what is the probability of this
and this added together
- 150 - its probability so it has to be
a fraction I can simplify that of course
- or 50 - is 26 so if you take away the
26 that leaves behind 25 26 does that
make sense now just as a quick note
suppose up here right I had forgotten to
include the brightness right
what would happen what would change if I
hadn't included these brackets the next
line would look like this one take away
he's the probability of getting the ace
of diamonds and then he is the problem
that you've gained the King of Diamonds
that's not right is it cuz look what's
happening these guys are just gonna
cancer with each other and there's some
how you got that it's guaranteed you'll
not get the ace of diamonds or the king
of ducks I'm just clearly not true okay
so we're all done for matsing your way
out of that that's why things like the
way you set it up and write the brackets
super super point okay